[Musik]
hey leute heute machen wir eine ferrero
rocher torte und ich persönlich denke
immer so an obwohl das fragt sich mal
haben sonst als erstes in eine moschee
banks - - - in der mitte
das ist alles wichtig man hängt man
freut sich immer manchmal mache ich es
auch so dass ich das halbiere und dann
erstmal die creme aus lecken und dann -
auf dass es irgendwie voll eklig aber
egal auf jeden fall an die nuss denke
ich auch und an dieses schokoladige und
deswegen jetzt halt so eine schoko nuss
torte und ich habe den saftigen schoko
boden von mir schon vorab gebacken und
richtig schön eingewickelt in
frischhaltefolie das könnt ihr auch am
vortag machen und damit ich das video
jetzt nicht so langatmig gestaltet und
euch alles nochmal im einzelnen zeigen
haben wir uns überlegt wir machen daraus
ein extra video und das findet ihr hier
verlinkt aber noch nicht drauf klicken
ihr müsst jetzt erst mal hier zu ende
gucken also ich habe jetzt hier die
zutaten für die krähen die zeige ich
euch jetzt wir benötigen schlagsahne die
ist hier schon im topf außerdem den
starken töten und bacau nicht den trinkt
hier habe ich oder zucker zimmer warme
butter ouvertüre tat bitter genau
außerdem einen extrakt und salz und das
zeige ich euch die creme de bakker jetzt
einfach in die sahne einrühren und zwar
so dass die klümpchen verschwinden und
dann erst den haag einschalten und dann
lassen wir die sache einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
also es geht nicht ums auf kochen
sondern das ist ganz erhitzt wird und
ich sehe schon die kleinen bläschen und
an der stelle gibt jetzt ganz einfach
die zeit bitter kuvertüre dazu und lasst
es schmelzen und den herd könnt ihr auch
schon ausschalten
[Musik]
oh mein gott oh mein gott bitte stark
bleiben und nicht den bildschirm
aufessen
denn das ganze muss etwas abkühlen und
dafür gehe ich doch schon mal in eine
rührschüssel denn ich denke schon immer
den nächsten schritt bzw einen schritt
weiter dafür dass vergleich aufschlagen
in der maschine durch das hier schon mal
in die schüssel der küchenmaschine so
liga nach die jetzt gerade hergestellt
haben die geht jetzt einmal in den
kühlschrank die musste ziemlich komplett
runterkühlen butter puderzucker und co
brauchen wir auch erst gleich und ich
mache jetzt den keks boden ich habe ja
einmal meinen saftigen schoko boden das
sind dann zwei bilden insgesamt und
meinen tipps boden weil ich finde dass
das ein bisschen knackig also ich denke
sie das genauso und ich habe dafür
folgende zutaten einmal schoko
butterkekse ihr könnt jetzt auch normale
butterkekse nehmen und so ein bisschen
bacau zufügen hat den gleichen effekt
und zusätzlich benötigen wir natürlich
gehackte und geröstete haselnüsse die
gibt es schon fertig zu kaufen und etwas
geschmolzene butter und wir machen jetzt
erst mal die texte klein und geben wenn
die anderen beiden zutaten mit dazu
[Musik]
der keks boden ist auch schon fertig und
ich zeige euch jetzt hier ganz kurz
meinen gerüst ich habe wenn nicht 100
orten backe immer ganz unten eine
drehbare tortenplatte so eine flache am
besten dann meine tortenplatte obendrauf
die die jetzt geradezu mit az passt das
ist jetzt meine schwarze jetzt übrigens
auch beim shop genauso wie alles was ich
verwende das verlegen ich alles in die
infobox und darüber kommt jetzt meint
orten regel nicht auf 20 cm eingestellt
habe so den gebe ich das ganz einfach
oben drauf dann müsste auch kein
backpapier oder so was untendrunter
machen es ist total easy wenn die torte
fertig ist haben wir das einfach hoch
und dann steht alles und da geben wir
jetzt unseren keks boden raimund dritten
den fünf noch an
[Musik]
so der keks boden ist erledigt gibt
ihnen einmal ganz kurz zur seite denn
möchte jetzt auch nicht kühlen einfach
so lange bis wir ihn wieder brauchen und
wir widmen uns jetzt dem saftigen schoko
boden jetzt gleich durchschneiden so
dass wir zwei bilden erhalten und ihr
wisst ja bei boden und bei backöfen ist
es so es ist irgendwie immer individuell
wie groß oder wie hoch der dann
tatsächlich geht und ich gucke dann
immer hier sehe ich gerade der ist 4 cm
hoch so dass ich ihnen einmal gerade
abschneiden kann das hier oben wird dann
gleich gerade und dann nehme ich mir
jetzt hier einfach meine torben säge
stelle den 1 auf zwei zentimeter auf
beiden seiten so und dann einfach
durchschneiden
[Musik]
richtig jackpot denn das ist übrig das
heißt sie können ja okay wir sehen uns
dann in zehn minuten wieder die böden
haben wir durchgeschnitten gibt es
einfach unter einem küchentuch und dann
auch noch mal ganz kurz zur seite
denn wir fahren jetzt mit der creme fort
ich habe euch ja gesagt ich mache in
diesem video alles ökologisch wie ich
dann auch machen würde und ich zeige
euch nicht erst die böden und dann erst
die creme und dann die zusammenstellung
denn ihr müsst halt immer auch diese
wartezeiten ausnutzen und hier ist jetzt
die abgekühlte schokolade ich habe ja
schon direkt in eine rührschüssel
gegeben hier ist der schlitten auf sagt
wenn ihr keine küchenmaschine zu hause
habt mit eurer hand drückt auch kein
problem
und da gebe ich jetzt die restlichen
zutaten rein und dann wird das auf
höchster stufe aufgeschlagen und dann
merkt ja auch wie die salischen festwirt
und die butter schön cremig
[Musik]
das ist das ergebnis nach drei bis vier
minuten auf höchster stufe
ihr müsst halt echt ein bisschen
fingerspitzengefühl zeigen denn die
creme darf halt auch nicht überschlagen
sonst wird sie grüße dich und dann könnt
ihr machen was ihr wollt ihr könnt es
nicht mehr rückgängig machen
und falls sie sich nicht auf schick
heißt das sie ist einfach nicht kalt
genug die garage die muss wirklich
eiskalt sein das darf auch nicht lauwarm
sein und die mutter darf auch nicht zu
weich sein also wirklich
zimmertemperatur reicht vollkommen
und ansonsten einfach nochmal ein
kühlschrank tun und ich gebe jetzt schon
mal einen teil der creme hier auf meinen
keks boden und verteilter haselnüsse
danke für die sehr gerne die minister
habe ich übrigens vorher angeröstet und
schmecken sie noch besser
dann löst sich zwar die haut das ist
jetzt nicht das ziel aber sie schmecken
auf jeden fall viel besser jetzt habe
ich den ersten boden drauf gegeben und
das ganze auch noch mal mit milchgetränk
damit so ein bisschen fathi wird später
es ist zwar schon sehr saftige boden
aber mit milch hat man eben noch so eine
andere konsistenz und jetzt einfach
wieder das gleiche spiel also creme
drüber haselnuss drauf und dann wieder
den letzten boden obendrauf geben
[Musik]
so meine lieben ich habe jetzt ganz oben
noch eine dünne schicht von der creme
drauf gegeben und jetzt ist sie auch vor
dem austrocknen geschützt sagt jetzt
kann das ganze in den kühlschrank
wandern und es braucht schon seine zeit
bis es fest wird denn ihr seht ja die
creme die ist ja noch relativ flüssig
und wir wollen sich schon fest bekommt
und die geht auch fest durch den anteil
derzeit bitter kuvertüre und die butter
und ich würde mal sagen mindestens vier
stunden gerne aber über nacht und ich
mache das jetzt so dass ich dass ich es
über nacht in den kühlschrank gebe
die creme ebenfalls und dann sehen wir
uns morgen wieder in alter frische
ja so willkommen zurück in meiner küche
es ist der nächste tag und jetzt geht's
ans eingemachte beziehungsweise
eigentlich schöne äußere dekoration und
dafür benötigen auch die übrig
gebliebene creme ihr werdet feststellen
dass die creme total hart ist und die
erstmal so nicht richtig was damit
anfangen können da hilft euch aber
einfach das ganze eine stunde vorher aus
dem kühlschrank zu nehmen und noch mal
für 20 sekunden zuschlagen und dann wird
sie wieder richtig schön cremig und
geschmeidig und damit streichen wir
jetzt auch noch den rand der torte ein
hier ist auch alles schön fest geworden
jetzt müssen wir irgendwie den
tortenring entfernt ihr könnt ihr jetzt
nicht einfach abziehen und reißt die
ganze creme auseinander
da hilft euch auf jeden fall meinen
tortenring messer ich verlinke unten in
die infobox das hat eben den vorteil das
hat jetzt im gegensatz zu einem
buttermesser eine sehr schöne dünne und
flexible klinge und damit macht ihr euch
eben nichts kaputt daher einfach rein
einmal rum gehen und einen tortenring
entfernen
[Musik]
also meine lieben das muss jetzt nicht
perfekt eingestrichen werden da kommt er
gleich in die glasur
ja ja also ich hab mir jetzt hier in den
seiten müll gegeben hier oben nicht mehr
weil da kommt da ich wie gesagt eine
glasur drauf mit haselnuss kern also
sparen wir uns das und geben das jetzt
noch mal in die kühlung das muss
wirklich extrem fest werden denn ihr
müsst euch vorstellen da kommen gleich
warme quartiere um drauf und dann darf
die creme nicht wegschmelzen also ich
würde sagen gibt es schon für eine
stunde in den kühlschrank guckt ob wir
das anfassen können ohne dass krämer am
finger bleibt und dann kommt die glasur
obendrauf und die wird richtig richtig
hübsch also bis gleich so die kühl zeit
ist fast rum und ich mache jetzt hier
schon mal den guss fertig und dafür habe
ich hier einmal vor mich quartiere
außerdem butter und natürlich haselnuss
kennedy gibt es ja schon so ganz klein
und gerüstet zu kaufen und ich gebe
jetzt die butter zur kuvertüre und
schmelze das in der mikrowelle und dann
gebe ich die müsse dazu
[Musik]
und nachdem wir dann die seiten
eingestrichen hat könnt ihr auch sofort
ran an die deko ich bin dafür einfach
meine restliche creme natürlich ein paar
roche spa haselnuss kerne und dann
optimal alles fertig wir können endlich
genießen
und ja ich gibt zu diese taten sind
immer ein bisschen zeitaufwendiger aber
so eigentlich gar kein problem zu machen
oder aber sie hat jetzt die einzelnen
schritte gesehen
ihr könnt jetzt fleißig nachmachen und
dann genießen und glaubt mir allein
schon für diesen saftigen boden das ist
es einfach wert weil er ist so ein
bisschen die sage ich dass eine kreuzung
zwischen brown und biscuit eben ist es
einfach probieren und dazu dann die
rutsche creme dazu optimal möglich will
ist ja ich halte auch zu reden und wir
essen und euch ganz viel freude beim
nachmachen falls wie bisher hingeschaut
hat auf jeden fall ein dörfchen nach
oben da lassen ansonsten schreiben wir
den kommentaren von einander
falls ihr andere besondere torten
möchtet wie zum beispiel eine maxi king
torte schreibt zu in die katholische
verein ihr wisst ja die videos entstehen
größtenteils durch und dann würde ich
mal sagen bis zum nächsten mal auf die
kitchen
[Musik]